foreign
course on RPA UI path this full course
video will cover the core topics of RPA
UI path RPA is in demand and highly
growing field uipath is the leading
robotic process automation tool for
large scale end-to-end automation for an
accelerated business change it provides
solution for business to automate
routine office activities
so if you are interested in RPA and
tools like uipath then you're in the
right place
this video will help you understand the
concepts of RPA UI path so here is the
list of topics covered
we'll first understand what is RPA
then look at the top 10 reasons to learn
robotic process automation we will see
some of the real-time RPA examples
followed by which we will look at the
comparison between RPA tools like uipath
automation anywhere and blue prism
proceeding further we will understand
what is uipath and then learn how uipath
is installed in the device
then we will see the UI part tutorial
for beginners followed by which we will
go through uipath orchestrator uipath
robotic Enterprise framework uipath web
Automation and then we will see Excel
Automation in uipath as to how Excel is
used in uipath lastly we will see RPA
developer salaries skills resume roles
and responsibilities and finally uipath
interview questions that will help you
crack the interview with ease
I'm sure you are excited to begin with
full course
but before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our YouTube channel and
clicked on the Bell icon so you never
miss an update from Simply learn
so without wasting any further time
let's get started
this is Jim he is an accountant in a
multinational company he handles several
invoices and other Financial records
like monetary transactions liabilities
checks and ledgers on a daily basis one
of his tasks is to copy all the relevant
information from these invoices such as
the name of the company invoice ID and
data processing into a spreadsheet and
mail the sheet along with other
Financial reports to a superiors by the
end of the day as any prompt employee he
transfers all the information to the
sheet attaches the reports and sends
them over to his boss via email every
day but over a period he starts finding
this task to be time consuming and
repetitive frustrated Jim looks for a
way to reduce the time and effort it
takes to complete the task and voila he
stumbles across robotic process
automation AKA RPA using robotic process
automation he builds a simple bot that
extracts information from several
invoices into an Excel sheet attaches
all the necessary Financial reports and
sends them over to his superiors via
email at a specific time every day so
what exactly is robotic process
automation robotic process automation
RPA is the use of software with
artificial intelligence and machine
learning capabilities to handle high
volume repetitive tasks that previously
required humans to perform some of these
tasks include addressing queries making
calculations maintenance of records and
Performing transactions there are
several misconceptions about RPA RPA is
not a humanoid robot it does not have a
physical form and no resemblance to
humans RPA cannot replace humans or
replicate human cognitive functions it
does not have a brain of its own and
cannot perform logical or critical
thinking as humans do the working of RPA
includes four crucial phases one the
planning phase typically involves
Gathering the processes to be automated
identifying the test objects and
finalizing the implementation approach
2. the development phase includes the
creation of automation workflows as per
the agreed Plan Three deployment and
testing is a vital phase since it
uncovers any unexpected outages and
ensures a bug-free product 4. lastly
there's the support and maintenance
phase which ensures that the product is
continuously updated with smooth
deployment across the user base to meet
the objectives of RPA tools are used
these RPA tools are software
applications that can configure tasks
and automate them some of the popular
RPA tools in the market are uipath
automation anywhere blue prism
workfusion Pega and Redwood among others
when it comes to Quality RPA ensures
consistent error-free output leading to
reduced operational risks this in turn
improves customer satisfaction in the
area of delivery RPA can help decrease
the average handling time and this
enhances the customer experience and
ensures 2 24 7 business continuity with
respect to cost according to nascom
domestic businesses can reduce the cost
by up to 65 percent through RPA it
offers a higher Roi by driving positive
returns within quarters as opposed to
years other advantages of RPA include
reduced training costs minimal
utilization of it resources and easier
software migration today many domains
and industries like Banking and finance
it integration processes Human Resources
insurance agencies marketing and sales
and customer relationship management
readily deploy RPA RPA service adoption
has been showing tremendous growth since
2016 and will continue to increase
Beyond 2020. according to mckinsey's
research knowledge and work automation
could have an economic impact of five to
seven trillion dollars by the year 2025.
it will impact more than 230 million
knowledge workers which constitute nine
percent of the global Workforce
any company which is labor intensive
where people are performing high volume
High transaction functions stand to
benefit the most with RPA adoption
boosting their capabilities and saving
money and time
now that we've discussed what RPA is and
isn't here's a question for you which of
the following is not an RPA use case one
email query processing two data
extraction three image recognition
4. payroll processing
give it a thought and leave your answers
in the comments section below RPA offers
the ability to automate business
processes quickly and easily it paves
the way for digital transformation by
placing automation tools at the user's
disposal so what are you waiting for get
certified and become an RPA developer to
build a bright future in the field of
automation 10 reasons why you should
learn RPA
but before jumping into it
now do you remember the time you used
the digital calculator it may be your
Calculus class
it made it so much easier for you to
arrive at an answer
calculators undoubtedly helped you solve
complex mathematical problems which
previously required a lot of time
and of course doing manual calculations
have inherently several errors
but does calculation account for
automation
well no a conventional calculator
requires manual input
so this is partial automation
automating the usage of a calculator
that requires zero human intervention is
what RPA does
so what exactly is RPA
robotic process automation is the use of
software with artificial intelligence
and machine learning capabilities to
handle high volume repeated tasks that
previously required humans
now some of these tasks include
addressing queries making calculations
maintaining records or even making
transactions
so why is RPA gaining popularity so
rapidly and why do companies in techies
have RPA perspectives
so here are the 10 reasons why one
should learn RPA
so number 10 fast implementation
now getting data entry Bots up and
running goes quickly implementing a new
RPA Software System certainly happens
much faster than training a new person
you can have these data entry Bots up
and running in just days
in contrast if you wanted to hire a new
human employee you'd be taking a lot of
time and sorting out resumes conducting
interviews going through the entire
boring hiring process and then finally
when you find the right person you'd
have to spend time and energy on
training them
however in case of RPA all of this is
countered
and number nine we have no training time
so now this is an important one
if your process changes and the Bots
need to learn something new you can
either replace them with new Bots or
alter their programming
now that again goes much faster than
training employees for new tasks in
terms of costs training an employee for
a new task will pan out to be way more
expensive and time consuming
next up the Bots will never quit
now with RPA you don't have to worry
about employees quitting or dealing with
a turnover
Bots don't care how hard they're working
or how boring their job is or how
repeatedly they're doing the same tasks
again yes it would be ironic if the Bots
got tired
software Bots can work all the time 24
hours a day every single day of the year
at 100 capacity now RPA doesn't take
holidays it doesn't have sick needs and
of course they do not have unproductive
days at all
well isn't that a treat to have someone
who never retires or decides it's time
to move to a different job
next up minimal I.T resources
maintaining software Bots requires
minimal it resources
in some cases it doesn't it doesn't need
to get involved at all
your RPA systems will be managed by the
software provider the responsible for
maintenance and updates all of that it
completely takes the burden off itnc as
your company a whole lot of money
Roi is visible now every organization
wants to quantify their gains
many of these organizations do not know
how they should determine their Roi
but when it comes to adopting robotic
process automation Roi is visible it
defines a clearer path to demonstrate
its risk returns
complex problems can be solved now as
our data sources and analytical
capabilities have grown so has the time
required to build various reports
robotic process automation system is
ideal to for solution to solve these
types of problems
the system stores the information and it
can also remember and transform this
information very easily
that means this makes you auditable and
tax ready
software migration
now it's a fact that software migrations
are time consuming and costly
migrating to a new software could take
months and cost could turn out to be
tens or thousands of millions of dollars
what's even more frustrating is that at
all times certain features and
functionalities which may have
functioned in a particular way in a
previous version may not even be present
in the updated version
so RPA helps with data migration with
accuracy speed and continuous updating
of software
RBA has a free tier
many RPA vendors offer free tiers
some of these vendors are blue prism
automation anywhere uipath among others
the software notably UI path with the
Community Edition and work fusion with
their RPA Express
this helps lower the total cost of
ownership
there's no rip and replays
now RPA doesn't jeopardize an employee's
job but helps with the growth of new
jobs
to do your work you need some additional
software yes and virtual machines to
deploy fully independent digital Bots
but you may not need to rip and replace
your existing infrastructures
also there's a common misconception that
RPA could steal our jobs
well that's not true monitoring and
controlling these Bots are completely
the responsibilities of the developer
as a result RPA does not pull down in
existing systems but it leverages them
lastly popularity and high salary
according to Glassdoor the average
salary of an RPA developer in the US is
77 000 US Dollars and in India the
beginning salary for an RPA developer is
around 4.65 lakhs per annum
top tier companies like Dell IBM
Accenture capgemony cognizant among
others are readily hiring RPA Developers
now with that let's move on to the
growth projections of RPA
now looking at the graph here both RPS
software and services
increased by huge amounts during between
2016 and 2020.
according to McKinsey research knowledge
and work automation could have an
economic impact of five to seven
trillion dollars by the year 2025. it
will touch more than 230 million
knowledge workers which on which
constitute about nine percent of the
global Workforce
any company which is labor intensive
where people are performing high volume
High transaction functions will boost
their capabilities and save money and
time with RPA
now this is all you need to know about
why one should learn RPA
but if you're looking to become a
developer let's look at some of the job
roles and responsibilities
RPA developers are responsible for the
creation design development and
implementation of RPA systems
an RPA developer is expected
to provide Guidance with process design
developed test automation workflows
deploy RPA competence be it Bots robots
or development tools support the
implementation of RPA Solutions
create process documentation and also
assure the quality of the Automation in
this video we will be looking at the
robotic process automation example let
us consider a discussion between John
and Jim John is very curious and wants
to know how and where RPA is used in
different fields Jamie been a developer
helps John in understanding the RPA
examples even if you are curious to know
the applications of RPA then you are at
the right place so let's get started
the first example is customer service
let's look at the problem statement
a customer representative must
understand and solve the customer
queries carry out the necessary actions
while switching between the various
softwares and applications and inform
the customer
this must wait while the representative
is busy dealing with data sometimes
asking for information that has already
been requested this tends to decrease
customer satisfaction and extends call
duration the solution requires
identifying frequently Asked customer
questions assessing customer
representative actions in response to
those questions and developing RPS
solutions to facilitate those questions
when several sets of information need to
be coordinated across systems the
customer service representative can
launch a bot the bot completes all
actions in seconds with the Press of a
button
for frequently asked questions a
dashboard can be created a customer
service representative will fill out the
necessary information to receive the
queries and Bots will use that data in
multiple systems to complete the
transaction let's look at an example
consider a scenario where a company was
providing support to the client and the
company was supposed to handle a large
number of calls approximately 20 000
calls per month which required a
significant amount of time spent in the
support team because of the system's
complexity and executive's average time
was about 10 minutes the system was
inefficient and slow resulting in a poor
customer service
with the RPA solution the organization
gained a virtual team that can complete
the task in less than a minute resulting
in a drastic reduction in an execution
time
the RPA bot performs the following task
loading a comprehensive customer profile
obtaining a detailed building
information
user preferences and other user
information are being updated resolving
common but simple customer issues
let's look at the second example
Financial Service
Financial Service involves compiling and
combining financial information from
various departments and storing the
records in a system data is manually
extracted from a bank statements to
reconcile documents and Link them to its
forms using detailed spreadsheets
to complete the reports business rely on
Excel Legacy software and manual labor
which is tedious and time consuming
solution robots can generate invoices in
seconds prompting clients to pay more
quickly RPA in financial services tracks
and standardizes and validates payments
process orders and avoid Sellers and is
always on top of things such a
disciplined assistant makes the
customers experience less stressful
adding value to the service provider
RBA in finance eliminates the need for
Endless email correspondence and ensures
a smooth payment approval process
matches invoices to responsible parties
and sets deadline reminders
automated data entry speeds up the
process and relieves human employees of
huge tasks this enables precise and
structured invoice processing
consider a financial service company
that's having difficulty extracting data
from financial documents efficiently and
accurately in order to generate ratings
using RPA company implemented an
application that recognized and
processed data this enable declined to
quickly and cost effectively automate
the tasks perform the RPA boards in
financial service are investment
management
reconciliation of bank statements
organizing the finances
record of accounts receivables and paid
the third example is HR service
this operation includes numerous routine
steps such as interview scheduling
record keeping resume screening
candidate shortlisting induction
training and onboarding pairing and
firing plays a significant burden on HR
and other support functions such as it
security and Facilities Management
particularly for medium and large
businesses while it is expensive to
build a solution that encompasses all of
these functions and completes the
necessary task for new or departing
employees some employees can be sloppy
with recording absences vacation or in
general using the existing absence
management system
so the possible solution for this is RPA
can be used to collect and Screen
resumes and online application forms
conduct through background checks and
compare the information to all relevant
job requisitions this allows the best
candidates to be shortlisted
RPI can be used quickly to create offer
letters for new employees that are both
personalized and accurate and also
validate records by cross-checking data
such as absentee reports Against Time
logged in the corporate Network and
alerting when information is missing or
inconsistent
Talent acquisition team of a company
automated aspects of onboarding process
for new employees
previously the onboarding paperwork was
completed manually by one person
consuming a significant amount of
employees time that could have been
spent on more valuable work
this type of work that no one wants to
do day after day the company understands
that an HR department wants to provide a
digital and straightforward experience
the task required a lot of copy and
paste activities with the implementation
of RPA the bot completed the onboarding
paperwork in less time allowing HRS to
spend more time on corporate social
responsibilities hiring Talent
initiatives and improving a company's
reputation
the tasks performed by RPA boards in HR
service are screening resumes onboarding
of new hires attendance management
induction and training employment
management and Survey report
the fourth example is telecom service
the Telecommunications industry involves
high frequency of manual repetitive
rules-based processes all of which are
critical for providing appropriate
Service delivery thus the foundation of
telecommunications is made up of process
that are highly amenable to automation
for telecommunication companies looking
to improve their customer service High
reliability and accuracy of process
outcomes are required
solution the use of robotic process
Automation in Telecom reduces error
rates to close to zero improves data
quality improves customer service and
increases operational efficiency all
while contributing significantly to cost
reduction
RPA technology can capture the business
process task performed by a telecom
company's employees based on the
employee section A well-structured
workflow can be generated which serves
as the foundation for automated process
by mapping each process step with its
significant cost for manual execution it
is simple to determine which action
should be automated to maximize return
on the investment
consider an example a telecommunications
and Media company decided to automate
its order creation and service removal
process to cut cost associated with the
company Speed Booster discount service
and deal with a massive amount of
transactional data with the
implementation of RPA it becomes simple
to automate the order build process and
service removal activity
the task performed by RPA boards in
Telecom service are
it checks on the credit and SIM card
swapping the solution of customer
complaints quoting customer phone
numbers responding to questions from
partners
the fifth example is healthcare service
Healthcare Systems contain numerous
burdens and tasks that involve
significant resource allocation such as
claim management this results in high
operational cost and slow process
every industry has inefficiencies but
few face the healthcare industry's
challenges checked regulations regarding
patient data and lack of resources to
deal with such rules building takes time
after a healthcare service is provided
due to manual and repetitive tasks in
the management process
management process include document and
data input processing and evaluation in
addition to the automating time
consuming task patients can schedule
appointments without the intervention of
hospital employees credit to RPA
technology
along with eliminating the need of
resource allocation for scheduling by
allowing patients to reschedule
appointments more quickly this
application can improve customer
relations RTA allows Healthcare
Providers to track and document each
process step in structured log files to
comply with external audits RPA improves
data confidentiality because Bots handle
this process
let's consider an example daily a
healthcare organization deals with the
process of patient transaction Data
customer detailed recording claims to
the process and data reconciliation for
healthcare schemes are some of the
manual process they must streamline
daily the primary goal was to increase
the efficiency of existing approaches to
achieve greater accuracy with reduced
turnaround time
robotic process automation was
implemented at the most significant
possible impact was obtained RPA
platform handle claims processing and
held data reconciliation program
Healthcare was able to reduce turnaround
time with this solution
the tasks performed by RPA boards in
healthcare services are appointment
scheduling Regulatory Compliance data
entry and supporting analytics to
improve treatment in this video we are
going to compare the most commonly used
RPA tools namely blue prism uipath and
automation anywhere
so what's in it for you first we learn
why exactly RPA came into picture and
then what exactly RPA is lastly we'll
compare the tools based on trial version
based Technologies process designer
accessibility macro recorders
architecture learning robots accuracy
reusability pricing and then
certification
so without further Ado let's begin and
understand why was RPA introduced
used consider the process of onboarding
a recruit your organization the whole
process will involve tasks like creating
a new user account a new email address
access rights documents retrieval and so
on so instead of doing all of this
manually one can automate the process
so with RPA the user can automatically
activate a template for the onboarding
workflow RPA can help assess prepare and
create new Journey data initiate mailing
of offer letters and streamline the
information across different systems
so what is RPA robotic process
automation is the use of software with
artificial intelligence and machine
learning capabilities to handle high
volume repeated tasks that previously
required humans to perform
now some of these tasks could include
addressing queries making calculations
maintaining records or even making
transactions
now rbe tools are the software through
which one can configure tasks that are
to be automated so some of the widely
used tools are uipath Studio automation
anywhere blue prism work Fusion among
others
now assuming you have a basic
understanding of RPA let's go on and
compare the popularly used tools
first up is trial version every tool
generally offers a trial version for its
users to get acquainted with the tool
this helps the users understand the tool
better and decide if they want to
proceed with using the tool
blueprism offers a free trial version
it's available in two options either on
the cloud or on the local computer
uipath also offers a free edition both
trial and license versions are available
automation anywhere offers a free
community version and both trial and
licensed versions are available
next up is base Technologies
base Technologies Define the technology
with which the software was built blue
prism is based on C sharp uipath is
based on Microsoft vendors like
SharePoint kibana and elasticsearch
while automation anywhere is based on
Modern Java Technologies
foreign
the third feature of comparison is
process designer
blue prism enables you to create design
edit as well as test business processes
from the visual business object
now a vbo is like an adapter provided by
Blue prism for communicating with an
application
each visual business object implements a
specific set of operations on an
application's user interface
so these are basically like objects that
encapsulate a particular functional
logic
UI path on the other hand acts as a
visual process designer with developer
friendly options
now a visual process designer is a
dashboard consisting of various tools
through which the developer can Define
the automation tasks
automation anywhere is developer
friendly with the visual interface built
for business users along with Advanced
features for developers business users
and developers can work side by side to
build Bots they can see the visual
interface and code in a single screen
the next feature of comparison is
accessibility
blue prism offers browser-based access
only uipath and automation anywhere on
the contrary or for both application
based and browser-based accessibility
in case of automation anywhere the
control room can be accessed with a
browser or a mobile application this is
the only platform where users can create
bots on any device or any operating
system
moving on to the next feature
learning now in case of Blue prism the
user should have the necessary knowledge
of programming he should be able to
create business objects and manage them
in the control center
uipath enables you to design automation
processes visually through diagrams the
developer need not know a programming
language in particular
when it comes to automation anywhere it
is developer friendly and offers both
Visual and programming features business
users can build Bots with the help of
track and drop features beginners
benefit from the built-in product
walkthrough
next up is robots now before we jump in
let's discuss what the different types
of bots are there are two types of ports
you have the front office Bots whose
deployment is in the user's control
you also have back office Bots and it
can run on locked machines from an
orchestrator the user may not be
actively involved in its working
so moving on to the comparison
low prism offers back office automation
only uipath and automation anywhere
offer both front and back office
automation
in case of automation anywhere the HBC
or the human bot collaboration feature
enables humans and Bots to work together
to complete a task and also to manage
exceptions and escalations
moving on the next feature is macro
recorder
or the macro recorder allows you to
record keyboard activities and mouse
events to generate automation Scripts
these activities are arranged based on
the order or sequence of actions being
performed on the screen
so moving on to the comparison blue
prism does not use a macro recorder
uipath makes use of a mac2 recorder to
enable fast process mapping automation
anywhere offers a universal recorder so
that the user need not select different
recorders for different tasks
moving on to the next feature
architecture
an application that runs on the client
side and accesses the remote server for
information uses a client server
architecture whereas an application that
runs entirely on a web browser uses the
web architecture
in case of a client server architecture
the user interaction with the server is
always through a user interface or
application on the client side
on the other hand in a web application
the user interaction is Thoroughly
through a web browser
now blue prism and uipath both
incorporate a client server architecture
automation anywhere incorporates a cloud
native web-based microservices
architecture it is the only platform
that provides a complete digital worker
Solution on the web users with any skill
level can instantly start building
robots on a browser without any heavy
installation
the next feature is accuracy
blue prism is accurate for desktop web
and Citrix automation uipath shines in
Citrix automation designed for BPO
automation
and automation anywhere shines in
settings automation with AI Sense
Technology
well any automation solution built using
a virtual desktop or bill to work in
Virtual desktops is called Citrix
automation
moving on to the next feature
reusability
view prism consists of a library of
business objects that can be reused
across multiple methods it also offers
High reliability
in the case of uipath the processes can
be used for various synthesis services
with several workflow modules as a
result uipath offers a high degree of
usability and moderate reliability
in the case of automation anywhere apart
from the standard common Library users
can develop custom actions upload and
manage packages in their Enterprise
control room every bot created in
automation anywhere is reusable
the bot store has hundreds of
pre-configured bots and digital workers
to kick-start a user's RPA Journey
next up is pricing blue prism has a high
cost of acquisition it also offers
restricted training
uipath offers effective Pleasant
entry-level pricing
automation anywhere offers attractive
its users also experience the lowest
total cost of ownership because of its
native capabilities and web-based
architecture
moving on to the last feature
certifications
blue prism offers several certifications
like blue prison professional developer
blue prism ROM architect among others
uipath provides free online training and
certification programs like RPA
developer Advanced certification
automation anywhere university offers
free online training and certification
programs for both students and advanced
practitioners
professionals can also Avail job role
specific certifications
there are several RPA tools in the
market today however blue prism
automation anywhere and uipath are
leading the market let's get started
with what is uipath
UI path is a robotic process automation
tool for large scale end-to-end
automation for an accelerated business
change it provides solution for business
to automate routine office activities
it uses a variety of methods to
transform tedious tasks into automated
process
Danielle dines and Maria stirka Romanian
entrepreneurs founded uipath in
Bucharest in 2005.
the first uipa desktop automation
product line was launched in 2013 giving
business RPA tools to automate manual
and repetitive back office task
let's look at the features of uipath